hello and welcome to this video channel
chess-playing 1c3 it's not something
that you can exploit just play normal
stuff and get get it over with okay this
is not a bullet game the obviously
thinks it's a bullet game i just wants
to play as quickly as possible
which is kind of successful it's very
quick was hoping for that that I get to
swooping in
she's four really
Wow okay so what are you playing against
each five then
let's see
hmm remarkable um as you want to go g5
or what is the thing I mean he probably
doesn't want to do anything me just
blitz us out a crap setup to be honest
if I
the sentence like what is his intention
s is probably really useless there
there's no particular intention
all right so what is what is still what
is happening here
[Music]
- f5 or something maybe if I go if I
take on g4
you
right
okay
take on g4 Knight 64
94 city for more yeah that is kind of
okay certainly for me but not sure it is
best is it the best we don't know we
don't know
I don't think that was the best what I
did
we have to make more mistakes too
position that is somehow worse but
it wasn't great what I did I just want
to exchange this bishop way a g5
there is now almost no sensible way for
him to prevent it
Quincy one is not a playable move
okay um just take it yeah I guess I just
take it now do we play for immediate
kill with c4 or do I just state that
I've been better with slow moves tough
call I think I can do this already
I mean blacks whites position looks so
awful but you can probably do this
immediately yeah that that was something
that I wasn't so sure of how I should
should answer that
you
you
you
and there's probably shouldn't have
played the immediate see for it is
probably a bit too I brought it was a
bit too much with this Luke edge one now
if I have to play stuff like this it's a
little bit awkward really a bit awkward
I don't know Queen eight five is awesome
that makes a ton of sense
yeah
let's do it
look da next
should this game should be over already
I made a I really did not punish this
enough absolutely not
it's still it's still a game medicine
beam
know how to how to convert
always still something that I would want
like I would like to do it anyway
you
wants to go too deep
it seems
I have F form also good square
ultimately it's about the bishop on f3
which is just terrible
Lagoon ig6 than 95 check is going to be
nice reply
you
hmm yeah it's not again I'm I didn't do
it right
this should
[Music]
it should have been over quite a while
ago
[Music]
Queen f5 this knowledge for that's good
with 20 seconds on the clock you can be
thankful for those moles
now
about him I mean like you here right is
strategically completely lost and I
shouldn't shouldn't have to solve
problems really like this is just just
lost to achieve strategically lost but
tons of weaknesses no space I'm not
really surprised at the engine is on 2+2
and I'm not not totally certain what I
did wrong
maybe maybe yeah yeah something
something here
I mean again it takes it takes many
mistakes who to spoil it and I'm I
didn't spot anything up to this like
here this is completely okay the engine
now wants to play see for me I don't
really mind this so much and now now see
for is it might be objectively right and
it there the engine likes it
yeah it was still not so easy to do but
still there Queenie seven long castle to
spare I am especially better like had to
handle easier to handle probably I
should just move the millennium until
this is a bit wacky it's still good
young but not waiting not winning anyway
[Music]
after Kingi won by now there the
computer says is equal yeah yeah as I
said I wasn't happy this is already not
so great that it's not so bad and so on
yeah it was I should have them can
really refuted that a lot earlier in
this idea to the c4 okay but if you're
just something like this and castlelong
you're just going to witness on account
of those bad pieces and Dwight's
weaknesses all over the place okay yes
thanks for watching